IL
N IGHT WIN A
L NVTIAROR WIL HAVE TO BE
OPERATIONE.L.7 ARS, ROMMAND O
DINGHE  O LADEN YOU FOR BEING
ERT THHTHAT NATOQU
NO-FLY Z UKRAINE.
IS IT RIGHT? THANKS, MICHA. WITP
THEY'VENCI
SUPPORT, THEY'VE BEELETHAL.TINGI
ITCAN UNDERS Y'S POSITIONUT
IMPOSING ANE
ABHT
>> UKRAINE
WAR?
WIN.
FROM A CONNTSTDP
THE IATMIANS I.
AS FAR AS WIN CAN GO THE
HAPPINRAN PEOP ATE THE UKRAINIT
Y KNOWHENG TFAR THARD. RUSSIS H
ETTHEY'LL
ENS. THE END OF THE QUESTION FOR
THUSTROOPS CAN THESTWI
IN ORDER TAIN TH
THAT REMAINS TO
WOHE
GOES THE BETTECHANCE F O IT
AGAIN YOU'RE TANV THE?
PARTISANINSURGENCY, I  YOU'RE TG
THINK THANS YES.
ABT NATOG E  NEC
FOR TH THELA WARFA N AFTEE
TIONAL FHTED
G TO BE VERYRUSSIANS.EONTINUE T
>>YO
AFGHANISN  S
RUSSIANS?
AFGHANE EEN.OUY,S NOT
RUSSIANS CAN VERQUT  DOWN INCAEF
SUPPORT E UKRAINIANS
PROVE THEM LETHAL AID ANTINUE TO
SO IT ISDINGLYFFICULR AN
OTHER URBA ONCE TH GETTO ATHINKH
FAVORSHE UKRAINIANS.
E ATH SQUADS WHO EDY AK
ZELENSKYY.
N FOR YOU IS IT IN PUTIN'S BEST
PELENSKYY HASSHOWRE CTAMINA
OUNSY, GOING TO  HIM AMAK L
HARDER, IF TLOTHIS
REMARKABLE MAN THAT'
AGGRESSION.
>> A YEAR AGO, YOU SAID THOWG,
ASKEWHDO I ASK WHERETYI ALWAYSN
RUIAME, YOU SAID O US.HA US?
>> TTION, HE'SG
NOW.
WE CALL N THD THE GAME,E,
HEIN OUTMANEUVER WORLD
SO OUTMANEUVERED, ING IN A POSSO
W ITUNFOLDS.
BE BECOME AN TEPARIAH.
HE'S FINDING THAEA
WAR.
D TO GHADNA STRONW THIS WAR
ANHOPEAINLY  Y IN FAV O.S,ASCONN
OVE
>>I' THA
THE COURSE OF YOUR LONG NEARLYU
OFPERSONALITY.T ORSIGHTSI DOTO
NOTED
YOU'RE SEE DISTANCE OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN? YH.
RAON ACTE KINDWAS
BUT HE D THINGS TO C OUTCOME TH
O THINGS IS HE STILL RATIONAL
KE UKRAINIAN ORSCALCUDID HED B
F HES ITTO AND THE U.STO TRY TD.
BAC
QUESTION ABO
WE HAV BE VERY CAUTIOUS OF
W,
WHERE HE FIGS  A
OES  TAROUS THAN WHAT
HE'SNG>> NA
WHEREVE
TIN MEETCE WITANDENT? KNO CERTAT
IT RIGHT .
N
NYWORLD LEADERG WITH HIM,
UNLE NEGOTIATE HISSIA.
SO, I DON'T SEAPPENING N